Oh doctor we've heard about you so we're
still in the dry period between seasons
and I'm sorry started to have a hard
time thinking of stuff to do for the
Sunday slots so what I'm gonna do here
is I am going to drill in more
specifically on something that I've
actually touched on before now a little
while back I did a video sort of
highlighting some of the key differences
between classic era Doctor Who and
modern era Doctor Who and one of the
things I highlighted was the doctors
reputation and I want to drill into that
a bit more deeply and really go into
details about at least for me why I
don't like how big the doctors rep has
gotten in new whoo now it's worth
pointing out that at the time of
recording which is between series eleven
and twelve that seems to have been
backed off and actually even in series
ten it seemed to have dial back a little
bit which was nice but for a very
significant chunk of modern era Doctor
Who it was a way that I would prefer it
wasn't first of all what do I even mean
about the doctors reputation well you go
back to classic error and the doctor
didn't really have one pretty much the
only people he had any reputation with
were people who we had actually seen him
encounter before the Daleks knew who he
was the master knew who he was you know
the those folks definitely did the
Timelords knew who he was he had a
reputation with them but when he we just
land on a planet and you know start
dealing with whatever was going on there
whether it was a monster whether it was
a race of people whether it was a mad
whatever it was they know who he was
when he said I'm the doctor they're just
like okay whatever they didn't know him
he was just coasting through I mean
that's who dark that's who the doctor
was in classic who sometimes he was
actually tossed places by the time list
but for the most part he would go from
place to place see something going wrong
and try and help and then leave
modern-era that started to shift that
was kind of the case with Eccleston but
when we got to Tennant the doctor
started or at least planted the seeds of
treading on his reputation now part of
that started with the reputation of the
Time Lords themselves now I still have a
fair amount of classic to get through
but at least from what I can see the
Time Lords weren't didn't appear to be
super well known by other races the ones
who did know about him like oh god those
guys but they weren't like things of
legend across the across the cosmos in
new whoo we did get that and that was
sort of where a lot of this started
because you would have characters like
mr. Finch you know say oh you're your
race they were they were so stuck-up or
you know jabe going in the the computer
refused to identify you because you're
supposed to all be dead it seems like
most civilized life-forms know who the
Time Lords are and then it was only a
matter of time before pretty much
everybody it's hard to know who the
doctor was now there's a couple of
things to talk about here let me start
by explaining why this bothers me
personally the first is and this is well
this is the big thing honestly and I'll
mention other stuff but the big thing is
it makes the universe small if the
doctor can land somewhere that he's
never been to before and peep
know who he is by name and reputation if
not on site he shouldn't be able to do
that the universe it's supposed to be
infinite he can travel across the whole
of time and space he should not be
getting recognized the details shouldn't
be getting retained that cleanly
generation after generation that he is
embedded in myths in so many places like
one place to place fine but this much
and I'm not saying there's no way to
justify it I'll mention my dislike of
this and be like well no it makes sense
because he can travel all across time
and space and he'll go to all these
places so he's saved these people he's
built a legend like regardless of the
fact that he can travel all across time
in space he himself last time we were
given an age on him was 2,000 years so
if his average adventure lasts what a
day even if he was you know even taking
setting aside the fact that he didn't
start traveling till the tail end of his
first word of his first body even
setting that aside there aren't enough
hours in the day
he can't go that far not with how how
many galaxies across how much time and
how many civilizations no no it makes
the universe small and insular because
everyone already knows him I personally
am fond of big worlds and the quickest
way to make a big world feel small is by
having everything circle around the same
handful of characters it's actually one
of the things that really bugs me about
Star Wars at this point and actually
it's a big part of why I didn't really
get into the expanded universe stuff I
mean some of it maybe I would have
enjoyed but a lot of it centered around
on Luke and Leia and yeah they can
having adventures or whatever but
because of the need to up the scale they
were still you know leading the big
galaxy saving conflicts like literally
everything seems to circle around these
people are on this family around the
Skywalker's now their kids are super
important like is there no one else in
the galaxy who matters no it's just this
family okay great and it's that kind of
impact when the doctor is so ubiquitous
that people tell him we get the word
doctor from you know that that for me
that should not be the case because it
makes everything small the universe is
supposed to be huge and expansive been
too big for anyone human time around
care to ever know fully that's part of
the doctors charm at his best and I keep
saying he because most of the doctors
have been male but I'm not saying that
to disregard Whitacre because she
actually understands this with the
current iteration of the doctor she says
the universe will surprise you that's
why I keep traveling and she's not the
first one to point that out the doctor
has said that in various incarnations
across the entirety of his lifespan of
all the regenerations and that is so
important there needs to be stuff that
the doctor hasn't seen and like enough
where they're not like scrounging to try
and find it but like that he can just
hit a randomizer land somewhere never
been but it doesn't feel like that a lot
of the time especially as the stories
have gotten more into the season arc
thing when stories were more
self-contained which again was a classic
error I think classic you know didn't
really do seasoned arcs it did it twice
it did it in the key to time and it did
it and trial of a Time Lord of meth it
didn't really do them and the whatever
impact was had in the individual story
only ever came up again if the villains
came back that was it but now because
the emphasis on series arcs and the need
to have
finale and in Oh big the universe is in
danger thing it that does create a
doctor with a massive reputation but
it's something I don't care for so when
did this actually happen I mentioned
that the seeds got planted actually at
the start of the modern era then we had
the first time the doctor treaded on his
reputation which was the forest of the
Dead this is the second part of the
signs of the library forest in the dead
two-parters the one that introduced
rivers song now he has this moment where
the Vashta Nerada are coming for him and
he said and you keep in mind if you
don't remember a thought we have they
they're like a hive mind and so they're
all connected to each other and they're
all over this library it says I'm the
doctor and you're in the biggest library
in the universe look me up and they back
off I don't hate that moment the reason
I don't hate that moment is because it's
not actually his reputation it's his
actions that make them afraid because
they don't know who he is by name but
when he tells them to look and they do
and they make the connections then they
go oh oh and that this may sound like
pedantic and arbitrary but I am actually
not only okay with that I do like that I
am okay with the idea that the doctors
left enough of an impression that if
someone like the Vashta Nerada who had
the ability to do it very quickly we're
to sit down and and like find all the
stuff that the doctor had done go oh
crap I'm totally fine with someone who
has to do make effort to learn what the
doctor has done then having that
reputation impact them what I don't like
is that people already know they just
know they just know who he is or the
legend of him
or they've heard of him no that's that
is that little stuff too far and again I
know that I know they can see much
splitting hairs but it does make the
difference for me it's also why I am
okay with the moment in the eleventh
hour and I mentioned this in my review
of that very episode I am totally cool
with the fact that the doctor challenges
the atraxi by saying is this planet
defended and they go through and they
realize oh and it's basically again what
the bastion Arad did once they realized
who he was by doing the legwork they're
like ooh okay bye
that's fine I'm good with that
where it started to go overboard was I
would say initially in the Pandorica
opens it's a very cool moment when the
doctor you know steps out and basically
calls out all the aliens and their ships
and says and basically dares them says
let somebody else try first they all
back off now this one as I said kind of
is the tipping point because it's not
all the way into the stuff I don't like
yet but it is basically right there it's
finally balanced on the edge because yes
these races have a reason to fear him
because they have dealt with him before
but this is him starting to turn away
armies at the mention of his name which
we then basically see play out later on
when we start getting into the silence
and things like a good man goes to war
and that one's actually really well
worth pointing out because I actually
like a good man goes to war as a story
and I like a lot of stuff that's done
with the river song one of the things I
don't like about her is this whole idea
that all this stuff was done to River
Song and to Amy
out of fear of the doctor and it would
be one thing for me if that was being
done by a race that had actually
directly encountered and conflicted with
him but this is just people who know the
doctors reputation they haven't met him
they haven't seen him they're going off
of records of his encounters in other
places and they're building an army and
kidnapping newborn babies and
effectively employing a cult because of
the doctors reputation and when the
doctors reputation gets so big that it's
actually driving the plot that's too big
the doctor isn't just somebody traveling
and trying to help anymore now the
doctor is space Jesus which you know I
say that that's a phrase actually most
apt for end of series three which was
kind of before Oh although even even end
of series three because there the doctor
is basically saved by his own legend and
by enough people believing in him now
that doesn't have lasting impact because
they do the stupid whine back time and
Rhett calm which I hate but that is kind
of the same thing
I like my silly little doctor who
dresses weird and has a kind heart and
sometimes a cranky nature hopping from
planet to planet and helping because
it's the right thing to do and because
it's kind I don't need the doctors save
the universe and it happened so often
and for how often the doctor has saved
the universe
I get the outside reputation that he's
developed in the universe at this point
I do get it but I don't like it I maybe
I'm weird because more often than not I
tend to like smaller stories over epic
ones my favorite film and the Star Wars
franchise is a new hope which is
arguably the smallest story I also
really like grow one for a similar
reason my favorite film in the Lord of
the Rings series is Fellowship of the
Ring because it's got the smallest story
the smallest scale and I like that more
it's more intimate it feels more real it
feels more personal because the stakes
are mostly just for the people we see
not for the greater world that word that
is full of people that we have never met
and don't know so maybe I'm the weird
one people seem to like their big epic
stuff and maybe I just spent the last I
don't know 15 16 minutes or so being the
cranky old guy going you kids get off my
lawn cuz maybe I just don't get it but
that's me and that's me getting off my
chest my issues with the size of the
doctors reputation again it does seem to
have gotten better in the last couple of
series wasn't too bad in 10 wasn't about
an 11 on that specific aspect there are
other things like just don't start a
thing about series 11 please like don't
but the doctors reputation what are your
thoughts on it do you like it big do you
like it small she does what I have
rambled about make any sense whatsoever
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it
there's the like and subscribe button
both greatly appreciate it I also have a
patreon if you would like to support the
channel and help me cover my bills and
maybe even one day get to do this for a
living there is additionally links to
things like a book I wrote and other
social media platforms that I am on go
check them out click on the links cuz
they'll take you places but you also
don't have to because at the end of the
day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]